uh i should say something about
a.i because i do think it offers a very
important
step into the future if you look at the
old testament the bible
there is this story about noah's ark
that you might
know about yes noah uh knew about
a great flood that is about to endanger
all life on earth so he decided to build
an ark
and the bible actually talks about
specifically what the the size of this
arc was what the dimensions were
turns out it was quite similar to um
that we will discuss in a few minutes
but at any event he built this ark
and he put animals on it so that they
were saved from the great flood
now you can think about doing the same
on earth because there are
risks for future catastrophes you know
we could have the self-inflicted wounds
that we were talking about
like nuclear war changing the climate or
there could be
an asteroid impacting us just like the
dinosaurs died you know they
the dinosaurs didn't have science
astronomy they couldn't
have a warning system but there was this
big stone big rock that approached there
it must have been a beautiful sight yeah
just when it was approaching got very
big and then smashed them
okay and killed them so um you could
have a catastrophe like that
or in a billion years the sun will
basically boil off all the oceans
on earth and
currently all our eggs are in one basket
but we can spread them
it's sort of like the printing press if
you think about it
the revolution that gutenberg brought is
there were
very few copies of the bible at the time
and each of them was precious because it
was handwritten
but once the printing press produced
multiple copies
you know if something bad happened to
one of the copies it wasn't
a catastrophe you know it wasn't
disaster because you had many more
copies that
and so if we have copies of life
here on earth elsewhere then we avoid
the risk of
it being eliminated by a single point
breakdown catastrophe so the question is
can we build
nox spaceship that will carry life as we
know
now you might think we have to put
elephants and
whales and birds on a big spaceship but
that's not true
because all you need to know is the dna
making
the genetic making of these animals put
it on
a computer system that has a.i plus
a 3d printer so that
this cubesat which is rather small can
go with this information
to another planet and use the raw
materials there
to produce synthetic life and that would
be a way of producing copies just like
the gutenberg
printing press yeah and it doesn't have
to be exact copies of the humans it
could just
contain some basic elements of life and
then
have enough life on board that it could
uh
reproduce the process of evolution on
another place
right so i mean that also makes you sad
of course because it
uh you confront the mortality of your
own little precious consciousness and
all your own memories and knowledge and
all that stuff right
but but who cares i mean we are not i
care about mine right and you care about
yours
no no i actually don't you know if you
look at the big if you're an astronomer
one thing that you learn from the
universe
is to be modest because you're not so
significant
i mean think about it all these emperors
and kings that conquered the piece of
land on earth
and were extremely proud you know you
see these images
of kings and emperors that you know
usually are alpha males and
they stand you know strong and um
they're very proud of themselves but if
you think about it there are 10 to the
power 20
planets like the earth in the observable
volume of the universe
and this view of conquering a piece of
land and even conquering all of earth
is just like an ant hugging a single
grain of sand
on the landscape of a huge beach that's
not very impressive
so you can't be arrogant if you see the
big picture
you have to be humble you know also we
we are short-lived you know we
within a hundred years that's it right
so what does it teach you first to be
humble modest
you never have significant powers
relative to the big scheme of things
and second you should appreciate every
day that you live
yes and and learn about the world humble
and still grateful yes exactly
you